Right, and our last but not least integration is with Trello.
It's also the latest one that we've started, so bear in mind it's pretty much still a work
in progress, but we do have enough to show you how it's going to work.
Now we're back at the integrations page.
I add a connection to Trello.
I'm going to connect to our fake test server since it's not at the stage where it can actually
connect to an external Trello API.
So after putting in my API key, the enterprise generates the link I'm supposed to go to and
get my API token, which I'm going to put in here.
Since I already know it, I don't have to go in there.
Now when I connect, this is going to look pretty much the same as GitLab.
We have the connection settings.
I can create a board.
I can select the list.
And I can make several of these.
So I can save.
Now if I go to a scan again, select a scan that has issues.
And select an issue.
I can now raise a ticket.
So as you can see, now we have two integrations.
So we're getting the dropdown to select which exactly ticket we want to raise.
If I raise a Trello card, I can again link it to an existing one or create a new one.
To create a new one, I select which board I want, which board and the list combination
I want to do it on.
So this is a high severity issue.
So that goes into must do.
And the low severity Trello gets kicked into the long grass.
So this is pretty much where we are at.
We're currently implementing actually creating these tickets on the remote Trello server.
So the create button doesn't do anything for now, but it will soon.
So that's a good one.